when a Muslim tells me how can God be
tempted my first question is what do you
mean tempted in what
way tempted in what way are you telling
me that if Jesus Is God he cannot be
tempted in the sense
that there would be nothing within him
that would cause him to
entertain and perhaps succumb to those
Temptations is that what you mean yeah
you're right Jesus wasn't tempted that
way but if you mean that Jesus if he's
God cannot have people challenging him
defying him and tempting him that's a
lie because people do that all day all
night to God even Muslims everyone is
tempting God day in and day out when you
oppose God when you defy God when you
challenge God and question God you're
tempting
him that's
external so tempting doesn't mean in the
the modern sense of the term tempting
even in the modern sense if are you do
you and I say this not to make fun do
you struggle with
homosexuality I do not know okay so if a
gay guy starts trying to hit on you will
you be tempted to succumb and have sex
with
him no I would not but he's tempting you
right I suppose he's trying to tempt you
to have sex with him but you're repulsed
by it right yes exactly but so that's
what we call an external Temptation a
Temptation from the outside that has no
effect on on you because there's nothing
within you that even caus you to succumb
to it right right okay but what if a
gorgeous Drop dead beautiful female that
comes and hits on you not only is that
an external Temptation now within you
you're going to now struggle with that
desire and you may succumb he tempted
you but there was nothing tempting about
his temptation but when that drop that
gorgeous Kim Kardashian look alike start
tempting you that will be quite tempting
right yes okay now what's my point the
Bible says God has been tempted God as
God has been tempted not just Jesus who
is man but there was nothing tempting
that would make God succumb to the
Temptation so the Muslims don't know
what they're talking about and do you
want me to prove it to you you want me
to read the Bible or you going to read
it for me uh I can get it up um but you
got to look at the King James I've only
got the Dewey Reigns oh that's that's
good enough because it's Elizabeth in
English because I needed something
Elizabethan now here guys let me show
you the Bible says God as God has been
tempted but there's nothing within God
that would cause him to even entertain
and succumb to those Temptations so yes
Jesus was tempted because he's God and
man but because he's God who is man he's
impeccable so no matter how much they
try to tempt him there was nothing
within him that would cause him to SU
come let me prove it to you go to
Deuteronomy well start with numbers
14:22
okay uh and yet all the men who have
seen my
majesty and the and the signs that I
have wrought in Egypt and in the
wilderness and who have tested me 10
times already and yet have not obeyed my
voice the word tested is the same word
for tempted that's why in the King James
says they have tempted me these 10 times
already H okay that's the same word by
the way in Hebrew test and temp so here
it's they translate test but it can also
be tempted so how many times they
tempted God 10 times but that's in the
wilderness so God himself was tempted in
the wilderness huh that's what it says
yep now go to Deuteronomy 6:16 and this
is what Jesus quotes against Satan by
the way Deuteronomy
6:16 you shall not tempt the Lord your
God as you tempted him in the place of
Temptation wow I'm confused so they
tempted God in the place of
Temptation that's what it says even
though you're not supposed to tempt God
right correct and Jesus quotes the first
part of that against Satan away from me
Satan for it's written you shall not
tempt the Lord your God and yet here it
says you should not tempt the Lord God
as you already tempted him in the in the
temptation but wait I thought God cannot
be tempted yeah he cannot be but it says
he's tempted because it has two
different senses and two different
meanings
right right now go to Psalm 106
verse4 vers now I forgot you're do your
RS right I am yeah Dewey RS may be Psalm
10514 because uh the the numbering of
the Psalms different I think it's 106 it
says but lusted exceedingly in the
wildness even durs of Psalm 106 yeah I'm
amazed okay go ahead read Psalm 10614
but lusted exceedingly in the wilderness
and tempted God in the
desert just like Jesus was tempted in
desert God was tempted in the
desert right and yet God wasn't man and
yet he was still tempted huh right wow
okay now what about the spirit of the
Lord has he been tempted acts
5:9 acts 9 verse 5 acts 5
ver9 says and Peter said to her why have
you agreed together to test the spirit
of the Lord behold the word test is the
same word for tempt in Greek that's why
King James says why have you agreed
together to tempt the spirit of the Lord
finish it behold the feet of those who
have buried your husband are at the door
and they shall carry you out okay you
caught it God is God God is Spirit God
as God by Nature without becoming flesh
has been
tempted but it says you cannot tempt God
but let me explain to you what it means
you ready go to James 1 13-5 this is the
passage Jus quote James 1 13 to 15 this
is the passage Jus say see God can't be
tempted son
sucker okay so it's say says no one
shall no one should say when he is
tempted that he was tempted by God for
God does not entice toward evils and I
like how they captured it see he doesn't
because you will be told he tempts
people but he doesn't tempt them to
entice them to sin so this translation
did an excellent job so reread it again
verse 13 so we get the point reread it
from 13 again from the beginning no one
should say when he is tempted that he
was tempted by God for God does not
entice toward evils and he himself
tempts no one keep going yet truly each
one is tempted by his own desires having
been enticed and draw there you go
that's the key there's two kinds of
Temptations you see
it there is the external where people
test you and tempt you and internal
where you have desires that can entice
you to succumb to temptation
right so God cannot be tempted in the
internal sense because God has no
desires within him that would entice him
to succumb to Temptation and sin that's
Jesus that's why Jesus was impeccable
immutable and could never sin no matter
how much they tried to tempt
him and that's actually proof that Jesus
is
God right God though tempted there's
nothing within him to entice him to
succumb and that's why Jesus never s
succumb because he's one Eternal Divine
person though truly human but as a
Divine person he's in control of his
human nature and emotions and could not
succumb to
Temptation right it was fut so what's
the point so what's the objection yeah
God cannot be tempted depending on what
you mean if you mean that there's
nothing within God that would entice him
to succumb and sin amen but that's
absolutely true of Jesus that's why it
was imposs possible for him to succumb